I actually read a story about a woman who
faked a pregnancy to fool her fiance.
And I started to dig into how she did it,
and I found out there was actually websites,
fake pregnancy websites.
And then I always start asking, "What if?"
I know the beginning, I know the end.
I always have to know that twist ending before we start.
If you've seen The Stranger, I knew what happened,
when she vanished in the very beginning of that story.
I need to make sure I nail episode one and eight,
and then the harder ones actually are the ones in the middle.
I don't like any kind of structure,
at least consciously thinking about it.
E.L. Doctorow had one of my favorite quotes on writing where
he said that, "Writing is like driving at night in the fog
with just your headlights on."
I just need you to tell me the truth.
The key to any protagonist is they have to be real.
There has to be that character that when you're sitting at a bar,
you kind of want to overhear the conversation a little bit.
The best twists come really from the heart.
You could have the most expensive car in the world,
but if it doesn't have fuel,
it's not going any place.
And this is true of all fiction we've ever done,
is your hero travels down the road of life,
and you've got to put speed bumps and pitfalls and detours.
It's really hard to figure out how to navigate all the hurdles
and the twists and turns.
And when you're giving information,
when you're giving too much or too little information,
it's a balancing act.
It's kind of always fun to sort of see where it's doing well.
I'll be sitting there going, "Oh my God, this is terrible
I messed it all up.
I was so good before, what happened to me?
How'd I lose it?"
And then five minutes later, you'll go, "This is genius."
What I'm trying to write is a story that will be universal
and I've always found the more specific, the locale, the
the more universal the appeal.
The themes are universal, love, redemption, family,
friendship, relationships, hope.
Those things are universal.
When I'm writing a book like The Stranger or doing the TV show
I become completely obsessed.
I think about it night and day, all of the time,
I wake up thinking about it.
I'm a distracted friend or guest, you know,
if you're talking to me, my kids are used to it,
like all of a sudden, I'll start giving one of these.
And the kids'll go, "Oh, Dad's gone off to la la land."
You have to learn by making those mistakes,
someone else can't make them for you.
Thanks.
Take care, guys.
Bye.